I kept saying this to myself on repeat
there is no waymo if you've worked this
hard that you will not be rewarded you
have to believe that this moment is
preparing you for something amazing that
hasn't happened yet keep going I
repeated that over and over and over and
over and over again as I wanted to throw
in the towel as I would start to bash
myself as I would start to feel sorry
for myself and be like nope there's just
no way I'm going to believe that
something amazing isn't going to happen
I've worked too hard and when you get
yourself into that mindset it creates a
sense of resilience and momentum and
resolve that you need in order to keep
going when the hits the fan or when
you feel disappointed or when life is
beating you down and that was the other
gift of that moment is developing a
little tool to flip my mindset when I
wanted to start to feel sorry for myself
so much easier to say than to do that's
why I focus on tools because we all know
what to do it's the how